this is a production of Cornell
University
good morning and welcome to the
agricultural and agricultural sciences
and plant sciences undergraduate
recognition ceremony my name is
christine smart and i'm the director of
the school of integrative plant science
I'm also a scientist and I studied
diseases of vegetables I was like to
throw that in because i'm not
exclusively an administrator so today
first i would very much like for all of
us to congratulate our 2019 graduates
I would like to take this opportunity as
well for all of you including the
graduates and the families and myself to
thank some of the faculty that have
taught and mentored your students so
faculty could you please stand up
[Music]
as as instructors and advisors the
faculty have spent countless hours with
your students and I have to say that
none of it is ever a burden working with
the students is by far and away the most
wonderful thing that we get to do as
faculty and seeing all of you graduate
today is just absolutely exciting for us
so we're really happy to be here finally
I want to welcome all of the family and
the friends who are in the crowd today
it's been a long journey for your
graduate and we very much appreciate the
support that you've given them so thank
you very much
[Applause]
the final set of folks I'd like to thank
are our directors of undergraduate
studies and the major coordinators so
for the agricultural sciences that would
be dr. Tony de Tomaso and Carrie
Richards
and with the plant sciences that would
be dr. Marvin Prince and Lyoko
[Applause]
so over the past four years I've had the
root privilege of getting to know many
of your of the graduates and I would
like to say that one of the things that
I've seen is how their confidence has
built over the past four years from
being very tentative and not knowing
exactly what they wanted to really
coming into their own and developing
life plans that importantly may or may
not change I've had discussions with my
own advisees and many of the students on
what about failure and fear of failure
and and if you remember nothing else
from today you may have heard this from
Bill Nye yesterday who is a bit more of
an eloquent speaker than I am but please
do not be afraid to fail
so I think that sometimes students get
in their mind that if they try something
and it's not successful well then that's
a failure and what do you do you're done
or if you jump into a position and
you're locked into that and I think
importantly as as Bill Nye yesterday he
explained how he went from engineer to
to public television on to advocacy for
science and so your career can change
over the course of the time and you're
really not locked in from my own life I
can tell you that I so I went to
Michigan State University my regalia is
free
and when I went to Michigan State I
actually entered wanting to become a
zoologist I wanted to study animals and
yeah the students that know me are
cracking up and then I took some classes
and I realized that when you're studying
animals they're not always alive and I
have to be honest that I hadn't really
processed that before I got into things
like comparative physiology and is
really hard to study the internal
physiology of a living animal and I was
just I my skill set does not allow me to
do that I was miserable and so I was a
junior in college and I didn't know what
to do and and I'm not plant sciences I
ended up graduating as a biology major
but I went into plants and then when I
graduated it was in no way Wow I want to
be a plant pathologist and study
vegetable diseases for the rest of my
life and then I want to become an
administrator you know that was not in
my playbook
I actually I wanted to be an ecologist
and an environmental scientist so I
entered a ph.d program at Michigan State
in plant ecology and I was really bad at
it like you know we all have our skill
sets but it was important for me to try
that you know it was my dream and then I
started to do it and realized this is
not my skill set and and when it's not
your skill set it's really not very much
fun and you realize perhaps it's really
not your dream so I was able to switch
and went into a program studying a
disease of chestnut trees and to be
honest when I started I was much more
enthusiastic about the plant biology and
the fungal biology and
so much about the pathology but as I
started to work in the lab and in the
field I realized that I had a knack for
it and the more successful I was the
more that became my passion so I think
that it's important to remember that
trying things and being unsuccessful is
just as important as trying things and
being successful so please don't be
afraid to fail without fail their
failure there is no innovation as bill
nye told us yesterday and you know as
bill and I also said we're hopeful for
the future because of you
we're hopeful that we'll be able to feed
the world we're hopeful that we'll be
able to have agriculture and plant
science in an environmentally
sustainable manner and keep the plant
diversity on the globe that there is and
we're hopeful that you will bring us
them so thank you
so on to the individual recognition it's
my pleasure to introduce dr. Tony de
Tomaso who is the director of
undergraduate studies for the
agricultural sciences majors
[Applause]
thank you everyone again my name is Tony
teach math so I mean that I'll mention
this I'm a weak scientist so and I study
the real waves as I tell folks seriously
I just want to first of all thank you a
crisp and a round of applause for Chris
our director I won't go on into know how
I got here but I'll just tell me one
thing if you notice for my last name you
probably got the sense that I may be a
battalion extraction I am I was born in
Italy the reason I say that is that
basically all of you are my family
la familia so I am just as excited as
many of you to have your sons daughters
friends siblings graduate and I see this
as my extended family so I'm gonna you
know thank you for all the support that
you've provided to our students and the
agricultural sciences and Plant Sciences
majors I know what it takes
I know I've spoken to many of your your
kids basically about the ups and downs
and one thing that was important was
that your support the family I was ask
them how what does your mom and dad
thing how's your family and they always
thought that that was kind of the
backbone so again thank all of you for
being here I know some of you have come
from real far to be here so moving on to
the program what we'll be doing is we'll
start with the Agricultural Sciences
majors and what I'll be doing is
announcing the names of each of the
students you've got the pamphlet the
program with the vials that are very
detailed I'm only pulling the snippet of
it just a couple of lines to at least
give you a sense of these individual
please there is so much more to each of
these individuals so then two lines that
I read do not do not basically summarize
what these young folks have done and I
have great hope in their future I know
I'm going to be following them
throughout their career so with that
we'll start
our first grant which is Elias Valera is
Elias here
[Applause]
so allows graduates with a concentration
in business as well as a minor in
business after graduation he begins work
at a New Jersey law firm congratulations
next up Elora
attea graduates and with a double major
in plant science a concentration in crop
production and management and a minor in
nutritional sciences she is currently
interviewing and plants a future in
graduate school congratulate I noticed
that they put some bouquet flowers here
so I cannot learn it's it's the Italian
thing sorry next Jonathan Bernier cherry
Johnny
johnny graduates platinum tamale
that's good that means he's done really
well production and management in the
mining plant greeting he will officially
finish his degree in December and plants
graduate studies where the don't Johnny
[Applause]
concentration in business and crop
production and management this fall she
begins the Ithaca College MIT master's
program in agricultural education
Illya buckler Jones come on
Alania graduates magna [ __ ] laude with a
concentration in crop production and
management and minor in horticulture
after graduation she begins work in the
school of integrated plant sciences a
weak science Extension II with the Jenny
kikyo Kniffin lab congratulate Jews
Chartres or as they say in French Canada
Chacon
man graduates magna [ __ ] laude with a
concentration in crop production and
management and organic agriculture after
graduation he will enter either the
organic vegetable or industrial hemp
industry okay next up we've got Ethan
English come on up Ethan
Ethan graduates with a concentration in
crop production and management and a
minor in agribusiness management after
graduation he begins work for Carroll
Vale Inc can infest can come on out
[Applause]
that graduates from Lodi with a
concentration and monitoring business
this September he begins work as a
consultant from a Y in New York City
[Applause]
[Music]
Robert Galbraith Rob come on up
rob graduates from Lodi with a
concentration in modern business after
graduation he begins work as an
agricultural investment analyst for
MetLife Peter Gaskell Peter come on up
Peter graduates full body with a
concentration in crop production and
management as well as minors in
agribusiness management and horticulture
he has already returned to work with the
family nursery and greenhouse business
MS Maya gets via to mom
[Applause]
I attract weeks with a concentration in
crop production and management and the
minor in agribusiness management after
graduation she begins work for E and J
Gallo in monetary operations management
I want to be there
[Applause]
can I at least this is awesome way to go
Sarah Sarah crack fire come on up Sarah
Sarat graduates with a concentration in
sustainable agricultural in the modern
environmental and sustainability
sciences after graduation she joins the
orchard management team at Fishkill
farms
Chace Haven chase come on
[Applause]
graduates from Lodi with a concentration
in my name in animal science as well as
a minor in business after graduation he
starts work at Silva's Holstein dairy in
California
[Applause]
John Harvey come on up top
[Applause]
[Music]
job graduates with concentrations in
crop production and management and
business after graduation he begins work
as a field technician for Champlain
Valley agronomics
[Applause]
Rebecca hemstead come on up Becky
[Applause]
[Music]
get he's back there that's good Becky
graduates with a concentration in
business and minors and business and
international agriculture and rural
development after graduation she will
explore work opportunities abroad
[Applause]
growing on kam de Rohan come on
[Applause]
growing has survived the effect after
you know coming from Nebraska so this is
big
Rowan graduates with a concentration in
mining business after graduation he
plans to stay in New York to explore
opportunities in finance and corporate
development
[Applause]
and a lame and it graduates with a
concentration in education and
communication after Cornell she starts a
fellowship for the Chilean vineyard
now that
and um baloney
manna graduates with a concentration in
crop production and management after
graduation she moves to New Hampshire to
work on a 50 acre fruit farm and cider
house
[Applause]
lauren mark duty lauren graduates from
audit with a concentration in crop
production and management after
graduation she will work for the Cornell
soil health plan
[Applause]
the postman
[Applause]
Nicholas graduates without Thompson
would concentrations in production and
management and business as well as a
horticulture minor this summer he begins
a horticulture internship at Harvard
University's Arnold Arboretum
[Applause]
and I'm narrow
[Applause]
graduates with a concentration in
business and a minor in agribusiness
management after graduation she begins
managing a 100 power organic Dairy Herd
in central New York
[Applause]
three smaller
I just get Sarah sorry sir I'll continue
so Rhys Rhys graduates with a
concentration in crop production and
management after Cornell we will
continue exploring dis passions for
softer natural resources in agriculture
[Applause]
sorry about that serum - five - my camp
okay Sarah males Bob come on
[Applause]
Sarah graduates from Lodi with a
concentration and minor in business
along with a minor in viticulture and
enology after graduation she begins her
job as a credit analyst with Farm Credit
East
[Applause]
Carolyn won't sir I'm not sure if
Carolina's here but I'll just quickly
read Carolyn graduates with a double
major in international agriculture and
rural development a concentration and
education in communication and minors
and soil science and global health this
summer she begins worked as an assistant
grower for an urban hydroponic farm in
Seattle so congratulations Carly
Elsie whole hair come on up Kelsey
delcie graduated magna [ __ ] laude with a
concentration in education and
communication and minor in animal
science after Grinnell she begins the
Ithaca College m80 master's program in
agricultural education Diana
Otis
graduates from malate with a double
major and environmental sustainability
Sciences a concentration in sustainable
agriculture in the minor in viticulture
and enology after graduation she starts
up one making internship with E&T gallo
[Applause]
there's a theme here with wineries guns
we've been in the wrong field okay
Christopher Pinkman
Chris graduates [ __ ] laude with a
concentration and minor in business
today Chris is working for Jeff calm and
Walmart ecommerce as a category
specialist
[Applause]
Hailie - it's not here let me just
quickly Haley graduates with a
concentration in animal science after
Cornell she heads to Wisconsin to learn
management do research on the 9000 head
cat French so congratulations Margaux
Margaux Whitney come on up Margo
[Applause]
Margeaux graduates magna [ __ ] laude with
a concentration in crop production and
management and a horticulture minor this
summer she will be the assistant grow
with space on Ryder farm which is in
eastern New York State the Niblo fever
al alvarez hello
that never graduates with a
concentration in crop production and
management as well as a minor in plant
sciences after making returns to Chicago
to grow its involvement in the urban AG
movement chase Spitzer
Tracie's graduates with a concentration
in business after graduation he is
commissioned into the Marine Corps and
will be stationed in Quantico Virginia
last but not least Bronte zing come on
in Bronte
[Applause]
so Bronte's from Beijing China after
graduation children will remain in the
US to continue internship work before
graduates go congratulate and again
let's just that one big round of
applause for all of all right
so at this time I would like to
introduce the associate dean for
academic programs for the College of
Agricultural and life sciences professor
Don Lyons who is going to be presenting
a number of awards for some of our
graduates
[Applause]
good morning everyone
so there is an award that the Plant
Sciences major has a privilege of
awarding every year and this year we
have three students who will receive the
Charles a drink memorial award so while
I say a couple of comments about what
the award is about let me just invite
the three students up here Jonathan
Pryce
Tommy sheeter and George stacks
so this award is based on the students
having the highest GPA during the three
semesters prior to this current one and
these students have excelled in many
ways I won't go into a lot of details on
that but I do want to say that each
student will receive a certificate and
also a $225 check now the money for the
check comes from the payout of an
endowment that was left by Charles a
ring back worth the 100 years ago back
in 1913 and he did that for two reasons
one is because his father William rang
was a personal friend of the founder of
this university it was as repor knell
and the second reason is because he
himself benefited greatly by the advice
that this College gave to Charles
himself for his farming so I want to
just congratulate each of these three
students on the behalf of the faculty
staff that School of integrating plant
science and I'll presenting each of you
with your certificate here
[Applause]
so again congratulations to the three to
the three of you next I would like to
invite Marvin Prince to come to the
podium
Marvin is a professor in horticulture in
a school of integrated plant science and
he's also the director of undergraduate
studies for the plant sciences major
[Applause]
it's my pleasure to introduce to you the
graduates and the plant sciences
starting with Yuki Chen in Minnesota
he's been fascinated with plants since
it was 10 years old at Cornell he
concentrated in flavor in genetics and
he will be going to the University of
Minnesota
after graduating from law hey guys -
Micaela
as an Army veteran with the love of
singing and plan
transferring from figure Lake Community
College she joined the Cornell
University chorus immediately upon
arriving at Cornell she's a member of
Phi Theta Kappa Phi outfit eyeliner
society's an active member of corn on
undergraduate Veterans Association and
worked in the plows collab with fungi
and the bacteria
[Applause]
[Music]
loses well
[Applause]
- effort into the plant sciences major
her sophomore year she was involved with
FiOS I also it was a founding member of
Epsilon ena which is a newer
sustainability and turning on campus
after graduating she will be staining
indicating starting a job as a research
assistant at the Boise constitute where
we should be working with bacillus
plants
[Applause]
[Music]
highly concentrated and plant breeding
and genetics and forth under dr. dr.
Michael Mazurek
and dr. mark written and her plant
breeding laboratories a Cornell
tradition fellow for all four years as
undergraduate she was able to volunteer
in Nicaragua in January of 2018 and went
to India this past January these chips
encouraged her to continue to travel
around the world learning about
different cultures that explore the role
that agriculture plays in community
revolver
[Applause]
Emily actually graduated in December and
she had to use the known as the Apple ad
around campus here
she loves apples she worked in a post
harvest laughs studied abroad at the
Norwegian University of Life Sciences
and was president of the Nordic Ski Team
she's already begun work for AG refresh
a company and specializes in
post-harvest solutions for apples
working as a technical representative at
Euston us she's graduating today come on
[Applause]
Hanah fuller isn't with us today she's a
double major in international
agriculture and they had their ceremony
she's there I just want to say a few
words about this remarkable young woman
she is graduating [ __ ] Loni and she her
recognition was she was one of only two
students in the entire college that was
recognized with the SUNY Chancellor's of
excellent award she served in the
Executive Board at Annabelle Taylor's
grocery worked for Cornell outdoor
education the answer pandora dance
troupe worked in the bowerly lab and
started as a cow's ambassador this
summer she was in India Tata for now
Institute for agricultural nutrition
with the Kyle's Global Fellows program
so how does not here
Denise yes Denise in the
first-generation mexican-american
graduate the concentration in human
health and a monitor and global health
for Connor Cornell brought engaging
collaborative international local
opportunities through research extension
and project implementation she
discovered in just the social justice
human rights and public health their
involvement with the committee of us
Latin American relations and she also
helped found a lead nature Rx a student
organization of foster spending time
outside a nature to improve one's
overall health
[Applause]
Parenthood see he really liked his time
at Cornell he loved its classes they
were fun and interesting
he played club soccer is a fly off the
side and everywhere in between his
family and friends are wonderful and
supportive
[Applause]
Gabriel's interested in the intersection
of design in a controlled environment
agriculture as a sophomore he
transferred in the plant sciences from
biological sciences after becoming
involved in the hydroponics Club since
then his passion interest in CDA has
deepened and he has been the primary
investigator of his own research into
the performance of hydroponic Jurgen
lettuce at the gap graduation game we'll
be working at an egg body a robotics
oil-based greenhouse
Simone Linda
what eccentric student viticulture
homology and we spending the next few
years
harvest hopping to gain experience in
the wine industry her fond memories of
Cornell include reminisces of her time
as a resident advisor to freshman her
lasting contribution will be here
insistent at the placement of a printer
at a plants Alliance lounge and she says
when she graduates and makes lots of
money she's going to provide free
printing for all this
[Applause]
Oh Amy
after graduating [ __ ] laude Maui is going
to attend graduate graduate programs and
molecular genetics at the Ohio State
University and she has a university
fellowship to go there she was part of
the partnership between cows and Shane
University in China she would be
receiving degrees from both universities
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and chance Bertram Finger Lakes
Community College in 2017
during our high school years she was
involved in horticultural research with
dr. Steve Ryder's and then later she
came here to Cornell to work she met
plant pathology students at Cornell
Agrotech up in Geneva and became
interested in disease plants and
vegetables sort of like our director
Karen did research in various plant
pathology labs throughout her years as
an undergraduate
today she's graduating [ __ ] laude it will
start her master's program at Penn State
University this fall
[Applause]
I'll obey
[Applause]
Margaret is graduating magna [ __ ] laude
with a plant and human health
concentration her favorite memories over
four years of Cornell are taking
agriculture courses in Ireland
at the University of College in Dublin
in turning over the summer at the
Cornell Botanic Gardens and enjoying
sunny days on the act by Sarah Maria
[Applause]
karen is graduating with concentration
implants in human health a minor in
entomology and a minor in theater
focusing on theatrical design at Cornell
she's been on the steering committee of
nature rx has served as the club's
president and she was a co-president by
office I the horticulture fraternity
you've already heard about Sarah
interned with ball horticulture Nick
gardens program and she worked with cam
Hudson as a garden educator and his
Stone Barns Center for Food and
Agriculture Sarah's interested in
pursuing a master's degree in landscape
architecture
canapé
[Applause]
Bartek you up in a small farm in upstate
New York his work at Sheldon farms the
sixth generation potato farm in some
town led to his interest in plant
science and agriculture during his time
at Cornell Park has been an active
member of Alpha Gamma Rho a nationally
recognized agriculture fraternity which
you serve on the executive board after
graduation
Parker will be working for Schumacher
companies in West Bridgewater
Massachusetts Patrick O'Brian
[Applause]
Patrick is the first generation college
student in a veteran he's the National
Science Foundation's fellow McNair
scholar at Cal's little fellow and his
time at Cornell he prefer he conducted
agricultural research abroad with our
international partners in Kenya he's a
proud member of honors fraternity Alpha
Zeta and the undergraduate Huerta
culture club for his forum he is
continuing at Cornell University
pursuing a PhD in the crop Sciences
section under dr. Newman
[Applause]
Roxanne Padilla
[Applause]
but comes from San Antonio Texas is
graduating with a concentration in
sustainable plant production her
curiosity and plants started with a
floral design course in high school that
it quickly shifted to an interest in
science behind the plans Roxanna has had
a very interesting horticultural
internship at the San Antonio Zoo last
summer Jonathan Pryce
[Applause]
Jonathan was part of the Cornell potato
breeding program for the last four years
the field technician helping in all
aspects of the program equipment
maintenance to harvest he's president of
Horace forum undergraduate culture club
he's been involved the club since his
first semester cornell playing a large
role in greenhouse growing in addition
to his leadership of the club after
graduating summa [ __ ] laude today he may
employ likes Thurman master potato farms
and agronomist and equipment operator
[Music]
sung Ching Chung is graduating summa [ __ ]
laude with a double major in biology
statistics of plant science this April
he received a cow's academic excellence
award for the double major category he
worked with professor pew got and
analyzing population structure and with
Professor yuan adverse Chuck drug
interaction prediction his efforts
produced first tooth first author papers
in April 2009 teen he presented its work
at the Ivy League undergraduate research
symposium he's been on the Dean's List
every semester was also named Mero
Presidential Scholar and at cow's class
of 2019 degree Marshall after graduation
he will pursue a PhD in computational
biology
[Applause]
towards that
more revenues families Christmas tree
farm in Boston spa
he worked in dr. Jennifer theaters lab
for two years and completed the research
honors thesis under the advising dr.
Thaler and Zoey
Gavin Pickering last summer George's
Summer Scholars dr. Larry smarts lab at
Cornell I protect his honors including
graduating summa [ __ ] laude with
distinction in research and NSF
honorable mention Plus membership in the
Honda cop and by office I honor
societies this fall George is excited to
return to dr. smarts labs episode HD at
plant breeding and genetics
Mark's a ball
alpha being raised in a small
agricultural community less than an hour
away from Ithaca mark began his career
in agricultural sciences although he
found his home in the plant sciences in
addition to working in multiple plant
pathology laboratories he actively
participated in the cornell tradition a
campus program focus on scholarship work
and community service there he worked as
a member of the Student Advisory Council
allowing him to further develop the
skills of leadership in community
involvement
I'm an insider
after graduating summa [ __ ] laude with
distinction and research Tommy will be
mentoring for a landscape architecture
and maintenance firm outside of Boston
in the long run she hopes to bring more
people to appreciate the natural world
by introducing the plants through green
spaces whether through public garden to
private backyard she hopes to bridge the
gap between age and society bringing
environmental consciousness into our
everyday lives Matthew Tomaszewski
Matthieu transferred from the college of
art architecture and planning is very
passionate about backpacking the
environment they plan to pursue a
graduate degree in the field of ecology
Matthew is also a four-year varsity
athlete and heavyweight crew team the
captain is a year
it's over
rates are concentrated in sustainable
plant production and minored in business
some of her proudest moments of Cornell
come from her two years as a peer mentor
freshman plant science majors
she has also spent time learning and
teaching swing dance as a vice president
of the Cornell swing dance club she has
accepted an internship working at the
greenhouses in Walt Disney World to
learn more about under planning food
production and science communication
[Applause]
James you
[Applause]
Maggie throughout the handoff China
and transferred from the University she
first majored in applied bioscience the
Nam Plant Sciences while minor and
biometry and statistics Maggie is
interested in research is starting
working in her labs started working labs
her freshman year she worked as a vice
minister in the HR department of Shane
University Youth League Student Union
began learning Chinese folk dancing at
the age of five it was a member of the
way he King dance club after graduating
magna [ __ ] laude she plans to spend the
summer travel around china before
entering the University of
wisconsin-madison for her PhD
change
[Applause]
grew up in China and transferred from
China ak University at Cornell Shiism
concentrating and plant breeding and
genetics in computational plant biology
she has worked several terms as a
researcher in AG or lab as she finishes
her degree and she's going to be
graduating magna [ __ ] laude with
distinction and research she's accepted
a piece the offer in a crop science
department at the University of Illinois
urbana-champaign
[Applause]
so anybody we missed actually one year
it happens so let's like give our
graduates
so before we conclude I want to give a
special thanks to those of you in the
audience who gave your love and support
and your money will allow us to fill
their dream of graduated from Cornell
I'm sure you're very proud of them as
are we this is a very bittersweet moment
for those of us and about me and staff
we've known many of your sons and
daughters for four years so I'm even a
little longer and I've grown quite fond
of that we've had these students in our
classes and in our labs we share meals
together travel together to exotic
places around the world and even the
answer together we will not forget you
and students now you're one step closer
to being our professional colleague our
last request is for you not to forget us
please keep in touch and let us know how
you're doing one of the joys of being a
professor is to get a letter from a
former student telling us about your
success and noting that you plan to send
your own kids to point out the major
implant size in their axons
in just a moment graduates will be
invited onto the stage for photos we
want to remind you all that drove you
nuts and the Chilean and into the
ceremony so as you leave to Cornell with
your diploma in one hand and your
e-portfolio and the other I want to
offer you a blessing on behalf of
faculty and staff and this may the seeds
of knowledge that germinated inside you
be forever nurtured with the sunlight of
curiosity
dureena passion and a substrate of
lifelong learning so that your branches
reach the sky growing ever upward to new
heights of accomplishment and
fulfillment but with the roots still
firmly planted inaccurate in a fertile
field high above cheers lies
[Music]
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu